I don't know if you were following the
action but Fabi and Wesley have been
knocked out did you follow the matches
there
yeah it's just me against the kids now
did you miss Hikaru in this event yeah I
mean in general in all these formats
it's been like among the very best
probably probably the second best player
in the world so I missed any event that
he doesn't play in he's slightly
slightly weaker what do you say to
yourself when trying to defend a
difficult position
depends on the kind of position there
are different techniques like the two
main techniques are one just trying to
to hold and the second is trying to hold
by creating counter play and like
knowing which one to use where is kind
of the key to defensive techniques